SCP-1730 is one of the biggest threats the
Foundation has ever faced.
SCP-1730 does not exist.
It was June 5th when the compound was first
discovered.
A large complex of structures in rural Texas,
about fifteen kilometers northwest of the
Mexican border.
Located in Big Bend Ranch State Park, it was
easily the biggest structure in the area.
But there was no record of any such structure
ever being built.
A massive network of power stations, containment
facilities, and research buildings, SCP-1730
looked like it had been abandoned for a long
time.
The exterior was degraded, but the building
was still operating.
A power generator had been running for an
indeterminate amount of time, even as the
infrastructure degraded.
Power flickered through the sight and fuel
leaked frequently.
But there was one detail that attracted the
attention of SCP brass.
SCP-1730 bore identifying markings linking
it to Foundation Site 13, a research facility
that was marked for construction near Nome,
Alaska.
But Site 13 had never been built, having been
abandoned in the planning stages.
So why is it in the middle of Texas, fully
constructed and long abandoned?
The Foundation needed to know more, and they
needed their best to investigate.
It was time to call in the “Game Wardens”.
Apollo-3, the mobile task force used to investigate
dangerous sites, was brought in, and five
elite agents were briefed and sent in - Ross,
Houston, Noah, Ohalo, and Vigo.
It didn’t take long for them to discover
that something was very wrong with the site
of SCP-1730.
The facility was located in the middle of
south Texas - but the local flora surrounding
it was native to Nome, Alaska.
Something had transplanted a building that
shouldn’t exist to another place and time.
Commander Ross ordered his men to enter, with
Houston taking lead, and they discovered that
entry led down a long staircase.
They descended slowly, following a strange
light that no one could identify - but had
a sudden shock when they discovered that the
basement of the staircase was missing.
The light suddenly stopped, and it became
so dark that it was impossible to see what
lay beyond the staircase.
Upon probing the inky black void at the base
of the staircase, they determined it wasn’t
a fog or shadow.
It was a liquid.
And it was rising.
Ross ordered his men back, but Houston was
in too deep.
He couldn’t break free from the inky black
liquid.
The men pulled him away, and got him free
- but his legs were gone!
Not ripped off, because there was no blood
anywhere.
Smoothly cut off, as if they were never there.
And as they put Houston down, he stood up
- on phantom legs.
He didn’t feel any pain, but everyone could
tell something was very wrong with this place.
And the messages they started seeing on the
wall made clear they weren’t the only ones
who knew it.
“What Happened to Site 13?”
“Death Here”
“Not My Body”
“Bleed”
There had been other people - or things - inside
SCP-1730, and they wanted anyone who entered
to know that this was a very dangerous place
to be.
As they advanced down the hall back towards
the entrance, they saw what looked like a
person in the distance.
But as they approached, it became clear this
wasn’t another explorer.
It was an old, horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall.
Not by chains - but fused into the wall in
unnatural ways.
At first, the team seemed unconcerned - recognizing
the corpse as someone named Zachary.
Fortunately, command back at base realized
this as the effects of some sort of cognitohazard
- a mental infection - in the base.
They uploaded a filter to their helmets, and
the team recoiled in horror at the site in
front of them.
But the horrors were just beginning.
They turned around to see a shimmering, humanoid
entity in the hallway behind them.
As it approached, its footsteps distorted
the hallway around.
It pulled AP-3 Noah towards it, without touching
him, and as the soldier was pulled into its
clutches, his body started to distort.
Vigo was next, being grabbed by the arm by
a long appendage, and his arm started to change
color and distort.
But the foundation sent Apollo-3 in prepared.
Houston produced a portable reality anchor,
designed to handle reality-warping entities,
and with a flash of red light the creature
was revealed.
It was a horribly elongated humanoid that
only existed for a second before the reality
anchor erased it and restored the hallway
to its normal state.
Vigo would recover, with the strange red color
in his arm fading eventually.
Noah wasn’t so lucky.
He was already dead.
And had been fused into the wall just like
the unfortunate corpse.
These horrors had been encountered just by
trying to return to the entrance, so it was
clear the only smart thing to do was to descend
further into the facilities and get some answers.
As they advanced, not encountering any other
supernatural entities, they saw more evidence
of the dark things that had occurred in Site
13.
The infirmary had been torn apart, a cafeteria
had been melted into slag, and a large group
of containment cells ended with a section
called “Olympia Class”.
But while most of the other cells were standard
sized, these were over 100 meters high.
What had the foundation - or whoever ran this
place - been keeping in these cells?
They would get more answers as they made their
way down another hall, where they saw a single
television still working and illuminating
their hallway.
At first the television flickered, but the
image soon cleared, and the agents were able
to see what was broadcasting.
It was the interior of a containment cell.
And there was someone in it.
And they recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the SCP Foundation
- Bobble the Clown.
A predatory supernatural clown that inhabits
a children’s TV show, Bobble the Clown was
broadcast by an unknown source and could only
be seen by children under ten.
Originally seeming to be a normal kids’
show about a clown, every episode eventually
devolved into the murderous Bobble teaching
the kids how to do horrible things like arson
or torture.
The Foundation eventually captured and isolated
Bobble’s broadcast, but the clown remained
hostile and vicious.
Not here.
As the team talked to the Bobble trapped in
the mysterious Site 13, it became clear that
this clown was broken by whatever it had experienced.
It rambled, it hid from the camera, and it
was clearly terrified as it told the team
about the horrors of the site.
And it seemed to recognize the agents as something
familiar - but not completely familiar.
It claimed to be able to smell them - and
said they smelled different.
As Bobble rambled on and on, the agents learned
about a man named Emerson, who ran the site.
Like the Foundation, he was obsessed with
containing the strange and dangerous entities
in the world.
But unlike the foundation, he didn’t just
want to protect the world from them.
He hated them.
The entities in Site 13 didn’t even have
numbers - they might identify by them.
Emerson wanted to use them up however he wanted
and dispose of them - in something Bobble
called the “meat grinder”.
Entities that outlived their usefulness were
taken down below - and none were ever heard
from again.
It was directly counter to every SCP Foundation
policy - but this site had clearly been performing
these horrible experiments for years.
How?
And why hadn’t anyone ever heard of it?
The team continued to make their way into
the facility, but their signals were lost
as they entered the cryogenics unit.
By the time contact had been restored, they
were no longer alone.
There were survivors.
Both agents of the foundation - and survivors
of the facility.
And they were angry.
With no way out and massively outnumbered,
they called for backup.
Mobile Task Force T-5, also known as “Samsara”,
was reserved for the heavy-duty missions.
They’re an elite group of practically immortal
cyborgs fashioned from the flesh of a god,
and equipped with further cybernetic enhancements
to eliminate Keter-level threats and to protect
themselves from cognitohazards.
They were sent in through a drainage gate
to look for survivors and neutralize whatever
lay within.
They didn’t know what to expect, but they
knew one thing - no one who had been sent
in had come out.
It wasn’t long before they realized how
dangerous this mission would be.
As they came across some large gated drainage
pipes, they could see at least twenty charred
bodies of humanoids pushed up against the
gate, some reaching their hands through.
Whatever had happened in Site 13, these unfortunate
beings had been desperate to escape.
As they made their way down the drainage pipe,
they could feel it getting hotter, as if they
were nearing an energy source.
And there was one other odd thing about the
pipe.
It was draining inward, not out.
They made their way to a control room, where
many of the consoles had been destroyed.
Looking through a window, their view was obscured
by a mysterious black mass.
On the control panels, they could read terms
like “incinerator” and “body pit access”.
They split up, trying to find answers, but
found many of their accesses blocked by the
black mass.
As the T-5 task force argued over their next
move, they were startled by a sudden jolt.
The giant mass had started moving.
The team watched as the mass spun, revealing
a giant turbine, which turned the inky substance
into a fine slurry that was then scorched
by giant streaks of fire.
One of T-5 shot open the glass chamber, allowing
the team to get closer - and blasting them
with a wave of heat.
As they descended into the chamber, they could
see a massive plant-like structure overhead,
which started to shake.
Suddenly, thousands of glowing pods were released
from the massive plant, and each one lit up
and let the team view the chamber more clearly.
But it was what was inside the pods that was
more disturbing.
Each pod had a humanoid shape inside, seemingly
reaching towards the team, until they hit
the slurry below - and the shadows went dark.
The team descended to investigate the slurry,
when something started to leak out of the
walls.
Looking at it, they could see something moving
within.
One of the team members picked the wriggling
object out of the black liquid - and it took
a bite out of his hand!
It was a leech - and there were thousands
more of them moving towards the slurry, consuming
it.
And as the leeches ate, they started growing.
They seemed to be moving in unison, communicating
with a larger being lurking at the base of
the slurry.
A larger leech, a queen?
Or something else?
The team wasn’t sticking around to find
out.
They beat a hurried escape from the leech
room, finding themselves in another hallway.
Whatever the black substance was, the entities
who had been here had used it, scrawling “Blood”
on the walls over and over again.
Occasionally, they would come across a drained
corpse covered in the black fluid.
Had the leeches bled them dry?
The facility was so sprawling that the team
knew that if they wanted any chance of navigating
it safely, they needed to get the lay of the
land.
They needed to find the control center.
The door read “Stairs to Cryonics” and
the leeches were nowhere to be found.
It seemed like a safe path.
But as soon as the team entered, the temperature
dropped drastically, to well below where it
would be safe for a human to survive.
The team’s internal heating system kicked
in, saving their lives, but that wasn’t
the only threat.
The team was about to encounter exactly what
Site 13 was keeping locked up.
As soon as they entered the room, sound ceased
to work.
The filters in their gear were overloaded,
and the team saw warnings around the room.
“Silence”
“Don’t Look”
A massive, multi-limbed figure emerged, with
each of its sixty arms moving independently.
The creature had no head, but a large circular
structure covered with ancient glowing symbols.
Whatever it was, it was ancient, all-powerful
- and deadly.
The team scrambled to get away, as the glyphs
on the creature burned white hot.
Anyone who touched it was burned.
Anyone who looked too long at it felt their
optical implants burn out.
The symbols on the creature were indecipherable,
but one word was clear and printed in English.
“EMERSON”
Site 13 was from another world, another timeline
where the SCP foundation evolved into something
horrible.
Ruled over by Elliott Emerson, it tortured
its captured beings, and eventually killed
most of them in the horrors of the incinerators.
When an escape threatened to destroy the facility,
Emerson successfully activated a device that
removed the facility from their world - into
ours.
Of course, as any avid follower of the SCP
Foundation will know, there’s far more to
the story than this.
Emerson may have been the start of Site 13’s
problems, but he was far from the end.
We’re talking about a tale so epic in size
and scope that it wouldn’t be possible to
fit it into one video - A tale of subterranean
horror, a daring rescue mission into the bowels
of Site 13, and an anomalous battle to end
all battles.
And you can look forward to that epic tale
- including the horrifying story of leech
boy, and the tragic saga of Dr. Hadley - in
part two: The Samsara Extraction Mission.
Trust us - it’s worth waiting up for.